the joggin experienced in the past when
there's been disputes or things have
been wrong it seems like there's a clear
path to to sort of work things out it
doesn't seem like a clear path
it seems like every day kind of gets a
little worse like people get ramped up
even more and then there's this event
that's looming on the horizon this
November event this election event I no
matter what whether it's left or right
whether Biden wins or Trump wins is
gonna be madness and chaos it seems hard
for me to understand that Biden could it
could maintain his health you know
through a presidency that seems very
challenging to me yeah I mean it seems
like he's been going down you know with
his coherence level you can kind of see
it over even months right yeah he's on a
really really rapid downward spiral
well it seems stressful for anybody
except Trump for whatever [ __ ] reason
that guy eats it up but for most people
running for president alone just the
grueling just the schedule that's
involved in traveling and doing all
these speeches and it just breaks him
down I mean one of the reasons why
Hillary lost was she just wasn't willing
to travel as much there was all these
different events that she was supposed
to go to she just couldn't go she
couldn't take it anymore she thought she
was gonna win anyway so she'd just say
it Laidback yeah yeah it definitely is a
brutal thing but it's really also just
completely insane that the two
candidates are these two people well
yeah first of all that the best that
Democrats could do I mean they had all
these other people that were well-spoken
yeah he seemed like young and healthy
and there was you know there's so many
that is hard to comprehend yeah right
it's really hard to comprehend that yeah
that you're looking at these this group
of whatever we have 350 million people
320 million people in America and this
is this is who you end up with [ __ ]
anybody but Biden anybody I mean we
don't even know who's vice president is
right that's gonna make a big deal
that's gonna be a big different cuz the
vice president is compelling and
thing he says gonna pick a woman whether
he picks probably it was gonna pick Clos
Bashar close showers responsible for a
lot of those guys skating in Minneapolis
so well that's not good
and then if he's gonna go with Kamala
Harris Tulsi Gabbard kind of took the
legs off of that lady yeah so then who's
left mayor Pete
he seems like a guy was just you know
like he's got a playbook he's kind of
like following this Obama playbook and I
just don't feel it from him at all the
least he's gay we'd have a gay guy in
office I'd have lighting people up a
little bit I believe that we had a
powerful gay leader I think it'd be
great for the country like I think you
know like the the one of the things
about Obama being office beside the fact
it being office beside the fact that
he's very articulate and educated and
it's a well-spoken statesman said it's
like hey look we're making progress
we have a black president like I felt
that I felt like a wave across the
country people like you you can be
present in this country like even if
you're born out of a single family
single mother family and you're a black
guy you can you as long as you got the
goods you can make it like this is great
this means we really are living in a
meritocracy and it would be great if
there was a gay guy that had the same
experience like like all the people that
are homophobes like yeah but that
[ __ ] mayor Pete he's got me yeah the
Bible says but you know what [ __ ] the
Bible I'm voting for that guy he's
better than Trump I mean that would be
great
but he's just I don't think he's the guy
maybe he's the guy someday he's also a
young guy right so who else who the [ __ ]
is there especially since it's gonna be
Biden and he said it's gonna be a woman
he's definitely not gonna go with Tulsi
she's too [ __ ] dangerous
yeah the the Democrats were scared of
her she doesn't play games which is so
crazy I know she's got everything
everything they want
woman of color congresswoman served
overseas two deployments
yeah she's got everything she's super
articulate super Arctic seas
level-headed super level-headed very
intelligent yeah but she's just not
corrupt
she's got this one problem problem I
mean other than that you look at it like
Jesus Christ this lady she's willing to
talk to people on the other side she's
you know she's a States woman she's a
you know the way she speaks she speaks
like a leader mm-hmm they won't even
consider her she's too dangerous
well so God says I'm going back to DJ
Dwayne the rock Johnson yes that's what
I'm saying back to independent yeah as
an independent yeah
and waning Jaco 2020
[Applause]